[Music]
so it's to tricks
something that people may or may not
realize it's the breadth of data science
that
we do in the data products that
we support so it's stitch fix there's an
algorithm for just about anything
from styling algorithms uh
algorithms that match our clients to our
stylus
algorithms that assist in various forms
of human computation
um algorithms that control batch picking
in the warehouse
uh pick path optimization through our
warehouses uh
what warehouses clients are styled from
by our stylists
uh the merch algorithms that handle uh
inventory replenishment
um allocation of that inventory across
size breaks
classes and again warehouses
we have a team that's dedicated to doing
demand modeling against the service
we even have a team internally we call
frankenstyles
um which i i guess i'm not supposed to
say but i just did i forget the
uh official term for this but uh that
helps us
create brand new um
styles uh that we roll out under our
private labels
um so just about anything it's stitch
fix or any aspect of the business
at this point has an algorithm or data
product that is integrated
to to make it um better and more
personalized and so
we as a data platform support that
wide breadth of r d and
data products and production so
as i mentioned we've got a few people on
the line today for q a we have bruce
wong
who is our director of data platform
um uh uh derrick bennett who
manages our data infrastructure group so
the group in charge of
presto spark um kafka druid
all of our data storage and related
infrastructure
laura john who is our director of
data engineering
thomas milar manages our algorithms
enablement team
which is the group responsible for
all the apis that serve out our data
products
in production to other engineering
systems
and then uh me as well
uh and so once we get through content
here uh
quite a few people uh to to aim
questions at
um and hopefully a broad array of
perspectives that
that we can offer um so some context
on our tech stack um we're a hundred
percent
aws shop um
we run a lot of uh docker
containers on kubernetes um
do a lot of data processing in spark
kafka for messaging an event bus
presto for ad hoc queries and dashboards
and
lightweight r d and then the majority of
our data scientists
are writing uh python and our code
on the platform side we also have a good
healthy bit
of scala and java as well as
some core core platform services and our
experimentation infrastructure is all
written in go
so some basic tenets of what we develop
for
at stitchfix uh one of the primary
things is
we we try to create autonomy across
all groups and and what autonomy means
for us is
um no handoffs right so we don't have
teams that are that are
oriented by specialization we have teams
that are oriented
vertically into the business or at least
our data science teams are
and we do that so that they can own
their research and the delivery of that
all the way from conception uh to to
production
um we feel like that avoids a thinker
doer split which leads to
frustration and and lack of productivity
so we do our best to avoid the think or
doer problem
um and and that means
r d prototyping and production happen um
with the same people involved the full
way across
um on top of that we provide autonomy to
iterate
um and so we we want that to apply
equally to our data science teams as
well of our as well of our platform
teams and that means
providing good service boundaries good
um
uh knowledge of who owns what and
allowing that ownership to to happen
with with full autonomy to um
control that space um
the caveat to that is doing something
for the first time may require
coordination right so if we have to
create a new
brand new integration um in into our
engineering systems
or um acquire a new form of data or
integrate it with something that we
haven't seen before that requires
cooperation and
cross-functional coordination but the
goal is
is to make that a one-time thing in
order
for uh iteration to happen on top of it
autonomously and in a loosely coupled
way
um so so right integrity of the
interfaces and
and
visibility uh is the key to achieving
that
um another thing to note about stitchfix
is we're not a big data shop
which is actually the size of the
department
um something something that we can
exploit quite a bit
so we only have about a petabyte of data
um we can debate it but i would assert
that's not a whole lot
and we seek to exploit that when
building infrastructure so
peter mentioned a couple of us on the
line actually
come from netflix netflix likes to joke
about
being a logging company that also
streams movies
the implication of that is there's a ton
of data over there which is true
it's stitch fix comparatively there is
not and what that means is that we don't
need to focus
on innovating
uh to deploy the largest uh
emr cluster or or kafka clusters
um on aws we can innovate on
the tooling and support to our data
scientists to iterate on top of our
stack
um and and be autonomous and and
maximize their productivity so it
really um allows us to focus um in a
spot
that isn't scaling to our data size
which is great and then leverage
the the work of of much bigger fish to
um to do that for us um
so so when we talk about scale if we're
not scaling to
to data size what is the scaling factor
for for
for stitch fix and it is the the breadth
of data products that we support and
just the the size of our data science
department which is
um you know over 100 data scientists so
um you know we we relative to
um even the number of data scientists in
the department
and certainly our data volume and size
the the breadth of data products that we
support at stitchfix is much greater
than
uh most people often expect
when they when they come in or hear
about the department
um so just a few facts to ground things
and kind of give
y'all a an idea of the scale that we're
running at
um we we run about tens of thousands of
batch jobs a day on our
infrastructure which is a scheduler
based on airflow and then
um like we mentioned a bunch of spark
and containerized jobs that are running
um so that includes model training
featurization
um analysis of our a b tests
all of our reporting and analytics and
dashboard creation
as well as ad hoc research and frankly
anything else you can imagine that seems
reasonable to run on there it's probably
wrong
on the online side we peak at about 2
inferences per second and that's
across the board of recommendations
simple tests on the online side of the
business
warehouse algorithms running across the
stack of all of our data products
our production jobs run mostly
spark sql and pi spark on the batch side
um
uh that runs on top of a system that we
call
um flotilla so so
on the big data kind of distributed
computation side spark and and
a lot of our ml work uh happens in
in single containers where we can just
push a bunch of memory at it
um again exploiting our small data sort
of
context um and and
that's happening data science code
deployed in either
python or r um and so
our pipelines uh when we talk about tens
of thousands of jobs a day
um we we have fewer pipelines than that
so a
a pipeline to train a model or um or
uh do various other things consists of
several jobs that span the stack of of
the tech so
there's typically some uh spark etl
that's breaking things into various data
sets by
you know maybe inventory class or
whatever the case may be
um and then feeding into these
containerized python are our jobs to
do some computation and then probably
back up to a spark
pipeline to consolidate things and
shuffle data around
those pipelines that we're talking about
again back to the point of autonomy
are owned end-to-end and iterated on by
our data scientists so there is no
handoff from
for example our data engineering team to
the data science team
as far as like requirements or specs or
shared code
the iteration is happening autonomously
on both ends and i'm sure
laura would um love to
to talk about that or field questions at
some point
uh we we used to brag about not having a
a data engineering team so that's
certainly something that we've
changed our mind on um along the way and
you know we get a ton of value there um
but
we have our special flavor of autonomy
built on top
um so to give you an idea of what
infrastructure looked like just a few
slides that might motivate
some questions we
do data acquisition into our environment
through state snapshots that happen
every night
of our various engineering databases
that
run our transactional systems as well as
constant data acquisition through uh
logging and
instrumentation on top of kafka um
all of that goes into s3 based data
warehouse
um and the metadata on top uh is mapped
into the hive metastore um
which makes data available to spark and
presto as well as
um all of our python and our clients
through an interface called
magic carpet
[Music]
on the kafka side we acquire data from
a ton of different sources so our
engineering systems push a lot of data
onto
rabbitmq there's a lot of stuff on top
of sqs
we're consuming all of our syslogs and
web logs as well as
external events instrumented inside of
javascript and internal tools and
external
as well as change data capture from
various databases
um floating around all of that
is pushed onto kafka
synced into s3 and then
optionally other other sources as well
so a lot of stuff goes into
elasticsearch
a lot of stuff goes back onto rabbit or
sqs to power other
applications and then a lot of it goes
into our online feature store
to serve out models and production as
well
derek and team have done a ton of work
in building abstractions and
interface um on top of that which
we playfully call the dmv
um and tooling on top of that called
caltrans and so that's basically tooling
that allows us to manage
that kafka pipe um and related ecosystem
that we call the data
data highway it's stitch fix
and it gives a fair amount of
abstraction to our data scientists so
they don't
need to know the details of operating
kafka but can
achieve the benefits of integrating on
top of it
inside of our sparcoverse we have um
kind of an interesting infrastructure so
we're running spark on top of
a variety of emr clusters uh and
in the slide here we're we're calling
that production and development but
there's actually
a few clusters
that we operate um the way that jobs
get deployed onto the clusters is
through an interface that
is uh developed in-house called zeus
so zeus is basically a rest interface
that allows job submission onto
our our emr clusters
those those jobs are then allocated to
one of the running clusters
uh as appropriate right so like we have
a few production clusters we've got
dev cluster we have internal sort of r d
clusters uh or staging clusters that the
team uses to test out a variety of
things
um data scientists don't know which one
is which necessarily so we can
uh you know re-span our our clusters
behind
uh behind the curtain and what the zeus
interface
does is provide a degree of abstraction
so that data scientists don't
have to worry about that and we don't
have to coordinate with them when that's
happening
so our driver containers
uh spin up on on top of a system called
flotilla which is the same system that's
running
the the single container
ml jobs that i was talking about earlier
which are python and rbase
we also use that to launch our um our
driver containers that execute onto
these clusters
that's all happening on top of
kubernetes
and from a batch perspective uh that
gets submitted through a system called
futura
which is basically an abstraction that
we've built
in-house on top of airflow
um a lot of the work that we do
um involves not necessarily machine to
machine interaction but
uh machine to human interaction and so
that includes a variety of business
metrics
uh reporting analysis uh self-service
uh through looker um as well as a
variety of
um richer sort of more interactive
read write type data products that we
expose into the business so for example
um uh
dashboards that will provide
recommendations to our buyers and
planners as to what inventory to
purchase and how to allocate it across
classes
or
tooling that can help design the the
frankenstein
type in-house uh
styles and and clothing that we are
developing
um and so that kind of stuff uh couldn't
be powered through looker it needs to be
sort of these custom applications and so
we try to make that
as easy as possible and this is a
illustration of the stack that that's
deployed on um
a lot of react apps going through there
we also use a fair bit of
observable and that gets
uh uh all exposed through um
a layer that we call daylight that
handles um
authentication and permissions and
logging
and um all of the stuff that you don't
really want data scientists worrying
about
or reinventing the wheels on at kind of
the edge of delivery
and then flipping over to the
online side machine to machine
integrations
into our various transactional systems
and our client experience
happens through a system called mixer
which is
um what is our
service mesh that production
models get deployed on it handles a
variety of things it handles reading to
the right
algorithms based on awareness of a b
testing
and things like
business line um it also handles
resilience so it deals with our
fallback strategies um it bakes in
distributed tracing
for free and it uh
is capable of shadowing traffic um
across environments so for example um
uh if you're doing local development or
um
have deployed a new model into staging
and you'd like to
shadow production traffic on top of it
that's a button press away with with
mixer and really
helps to flesh out our
development story for our data
scientists um and we've got
thomas milar on the line who is the the
designer of that whole ecosystem and i'm
sure he's happy to take
questions there um and
with that uh happy to take questions
from the group
and just a reminder of who's on on the
call
um uh we we've got bruce who
um in in a former life uh
over at netflix is the um uh
one of the masterminds behind chaos
monkey and chaos engineering and is
really
um focused right now on on platform and
uh
uh fleshing out our resilience and um
uh reliability story on the online side
of our data products
uh derrick bennett who manages all of
the
big data infrastructure so kafka spark
presto
as well as druid and
others that we've talked about on the
call on the laura john
director of our data engineering team
basically our etl patterns the way that
we handle data
and our core data model is
what she's focused on as well as
instrumentation of um
uh all of our uh online systems onto
our event bus and thomas milar uh
uh the online serving side and then i'm
happy to take
all kinds of questions as well so great
thanks jeff
um yeah so folks can feel free to
unmute themselves or um punch in
questions in the chat and uh the
stitchfix team will
be happy to answer them um i just wanted
to ask one thing
not to go back in time too far but um
i know that folks will want to ask lots
of detailed questions about your
your current systems your current
architecture et cetera
and it's awesome that we have so many
great technical people on the line
um i just wanted to ask from sort of a
more of a startup perspective because
we have folks in our community who have
all sizes and shapes of
data teams or maybe even not data teams
they might be a single
data engineer data scientist at a
startup trying to figure out how to
build a practice
i'm just wondering you know before
stitchfix got to be
100 plus person data team
what lessons do you have from the very
earliest stages
of data and nascency at small companies
how would you encourage them to to think
about building their team or structuring
their team
and what tips or tricks or
gotchas can you mention that you think
would be helpful to folks who are
just starting off on the journey of
trying to build a really resilient data
practice over time
yeah that's a great question um and i
guess for some context
uh at least a couple of us on the line
so uh
thomas has been at stitchfix a little
bit longer than me uh
but we we both joined around
six years ago um when the team was
nowhere near the size it is now so i
think it was between five and ten people
back then
um and and the platform team was almost
non-existent so it was
uh i think three of us um
and you know certainly none of that
existed
none of what we've talked about um on
the deck
existed uh at that point and the
challenge was um
you know putting putting ourselves in a
position to
to get to the place where we are today
um
and so uh you know i think
i think one thing that um
maybe we had an advantage of over at
stitchfix is
um you know we we kind of knew by the
nature of the business that it wasn't
going to be
you know a huge data shop right so like
we we had interesting data
and a sufficient amount of it to um
do good data science but we didn't have
um sort of this
massive scaling problem up front that we
needed to design for
and and we knew that that wasn't
something that was gonna
rapidly uh ramp up in the in the future
um and we we also knew that there was
sort of
uh an intention and and buy-in
um from all the executives at citrix
that
uh a huge competitive differentiator for
the company
was was gonna be our data science right
so like we knew
we knew that the team was gonna scale um
and so
so making bets for the future uh with
with that respect
um wasn't risky at all right like it was
just a matter of time and
and creating a runway for it and so
um with that in mind you know we were we
were making some like long-term bets
um but you've got to start somewhere
with only three people
um and so uh you know i
i came into it with a belief that if you
can control um
the way data is read and written you can
actually
create sort of an abstraction layer
uh between data scientists or people
operating on the data warehouse
and uh sort of the the infrastructure
that you want to future proof and so
that's where we really concentrated
first is um
getting that like hive metadata layer in
place
and establishing sort of the way that we
wanted to physicalize the data
um in the in the warehouse um
and and not making that optional right
so like that was the only way that you
could communicate
to the data is through um
uh platform supported readers and
writers and then you know that handled
the physicalization and metadata mapping
um and i think you know that was a good
guardrail
to allow us to kind of scale into a lot
of the the batch infrastructure side
um without um having to redo a lot of
stuff
and so that that was a good learning i
think something that we relate to
is um getting a really healthy
um messaging infrastructure in place
and so um you know now we have
something that i think is awesome with
data highway but that was
um something that that that i wish we
had done
a a little earlier so that's i guess
from
relative timing is like four years old
versus the six so
it's been around for a while now um but
uh was harder to spin up than than it
should have been just given the timing
there
um and then i don't know i don't want to
put thomas on the spot but
do you maybe have a couple insights
around the online serving side seeing as
how you've watched it evolve over time
um yeah
from the model serving side it was
it was really about i mean honestly we
didn't do model serving through like
real-time apis for a very long time
and so i think the i think that was
probably like
the right call is is you know figure out
the use case and
you know design the infrastructure
around it so in a lot of ways we were
kind of
late to the game with like deploying
apis and services because our our api
wasn't necessarily a rest interface it
would be
hey we're going to do we're going to
provide a data dump over to into
into a database or something like that
so um
i think the the the key things that
allowed us to
uh get up to speed there on the model
inference was
was like really analyzing the use case
and designing the infrastructure
around it eventually you're gonna need
apis and whatnot but like we didn't we
didn't dive into that
before we needed to um that was kind of
like the
a big theme in the arc and so also for
context there is
probably about four years ago when we
actually started getting into
like apis um the first two years was
mostly just just uh data dumps and that
was kind of how we exposed
uh models out to the business which is i
think relatively kind of uncommon
i think one of the things i would add on
that question around like how to think
about
the investments you make early that help
you later is
i've never re i've never regretted uh
like putting an interface in place um
to kind of separate concerns and i think
that's
uh that's both true from an engineering
and
data science perspective of like what
that looks like so
getting a good contract between two
different
uh two different orgs or teams or people
that's you know unified respected and
agreed upon
um those those are the things that allow
you to scale behind the scenes because
you have a predictable pattern and a
predictable interface
now those interfaces you build early on
i think there's an art to like don't
build it too early but don't build it
too late
um i think i think thomas has it had a
good saying of like
do it the hard way once do it the hard
way twice then look at like building an
interface
um and i think the time like you'll find
that
the investment you make in interfaces
earlier will pay off uh
long term because then that allows two
different teams
to kind of separate the concerns uh for
whatever we're building
and i i see that i see that in a lot of
the
investments that uh jeff and thomas put
in very early that a lot of those
interfaces are still
the same interfaces today that we have
uh they're just at a dramatically larger
scale and we've been able to involve
uh the systems behind the scenes thanks
to that
a little bit in the the history there
kind of piggybacking what i was saying
earlier
is uh you know the latency of inference
is not
so much an issue if you like batch
compute the inferences which is
something that we were able to leverage
at the scale when
for example when i first joined we would
run a nightly job that would compute all
the inferences
and load it into a postgres database
then the latencies
it's just a lookup um so the the big
thing that we've
like dealing with latency and model
inferences is always
an issue it's not it's not like a solved
problem it depends on the use case
um the general techniques that we've
used like we kind of have a
framework by which we solve latency
issues and
and it generally boils down into like
do less work um is the main thing so
often you'll see you kind of user you
know
to give get really concrete for a second
there's you know our
the first kind of model that we worked
on that we're using inferences takes a
client
and takes a style and predicts the
probability that they're going to buy it
and so you take your entire client's
table and you do it for every single
style
you're doing tons and tons of inference
even though in reality
in our product you only ever observe
like less than
one percent of those numbers um and so
there's like
key observations of saying okay we'll do
less work we're doing you know
100x more work than we need to and so
design the system around that and be
able to get
that confidence signal to allow you to
only have to do
uh the inferences on the data that you
need um
that obviously is a lot easier when you
have kind of apis it's a little bit
different
for batch compute so there's a uh
do less work make things parallel um
i have like a list written down
somewhere there's like uh
um yeah do less
do less work uh make things parallel and
then only
only at the last point do you start
considering using better technology so
it has come up where we said oh well if
we just program this and see
or something like that or or julia or
something it would be so much faster and
you say like okay that's a that's a last
resort because
what you're optimizing for is the rate
at which you can develop models
and because that's the thing that's
going to push push the business forward
not making an existing model faster so
you try to use
engineering tricks to make the models
faster instead of like
rewriting the model from ground up um
i don't know if that kind of answered
the question um
i don't know if it is awesome i also add
one one thing to
that is uh like we've had some wins
around like
represent like representing the data in
a smaller footprint
and so are there there's opti there's
optimizations you can make around like
if it can fit on disk that's one
optimization instead of going all the
way to s3
if it can fit in memory that's another
optimization
and every time that you're able to
represent the same data
uh in a smaller footprint you get a like
you get latency benefits because you're
uh you know there's less network there's
less uh
disk and io like the more the smaller
footprint of that memory
like gets you pretty good step changes
in in
latency performance um yeah so
that's kind of along the same lines of
do less work
that thomas thomas talked about but i
think there's also another vector of
like
are we representing the data in a way
that uh
you know is there is there something
there for us i think something that
uh we've learned along the way as well
as just maximizing sort of roi and so
like a key insight into that
is um the expected lifetime of
an interface that we're building is
several years
um uh versus the the
expected lifetime of a model is maybe
three months in production before it
gets rewritten or beaten by something
else and so
um you know if we if we spend our time
optimizing the
the interface that's great roi um
because it's got staying power whereas
if we spend our time
optimizing the implementation of any
individual model
um you know that that might have a
massive benefit for three months but
then it's going to evaporate when
the the next greatest thing comes along
one one thing that kind of bruce
reminded me of that uh
i wanted to highlight is like data
representation
you know a an example of an optimization
that we put
in was um these apis generally they're
feeding data over json but we have kind
of an internal optimization where we
know if the data
return being returned by a model is can
be represented as a data frame
and we'll use like pyro under the hood
but the really key thing there is that
that in that optimization is kind of
interesting technically
but the the key kind of lesson learned
is not that
optimization it's that we didn't put
that into the model code
we put that into the platform so that
any
and then it's to kind of just point is
that because any individual model
only exists for three months and we have
hundreds of models um deployed into
production at a given time
any optimization that we do tackle we
tackle at the infrastructure level as
as to the best of our ability um and
that's
really how we get leverage so
i wanted to ask laura a question since
jeff you hinted at the fact that
culturally
at stitchfix perhaps there's been more
of a focus on
enabling data scientists um to do
awesome stuff
and maybe even sometimes that's been
at the expense at least in label of the
data engineering team
um but laura's obviously you've had to
build build an engineering team so i was
wondering
um if you had any sort of feedback or
comments on
the challenges and opportunities of what
it was like to build a data engineering
team at stitchfix
yeah um when i came in it was clear
there was a lot of
overlap and a lot of duplication um and
people didn't feel like there was a
central model
and then you know given a lack of
ownership people also wouldn't feel
comfortable making changes to that and
so they made their own things and so
um you know everybody cares about our
data around our clients and
the shipments that we send out um and it
turns out we had like
four or five different versions of
client data that
didn't have the same definition but it
sometimes didn't match like we had
applied different business logic against
it and
no one knew which what was correct um so
there's definitely opportunity for
centralization
there um and it turns out there's like
quite a bit of data that ends up
being a great fit for for a central
model and so our team kind of like
decides what that is like what should be
central what is going to be used by
enough people that it makes sense
that we're not going to you know block
anyone from
you know we also just kind of like if
somebody needs something and they need
it now like
then you could make the thing now we're
not going to kind of stand in your way
but we do look for opportunities
and i think that's an uh an interesting
uh that's been a really cool experience
at citrix is that i get to just look for
opportunities
of like things that i see people doing
that should be more central and so
um our team has built out some uh
frameworks for kind of like
um consolidating business logic and uh
letting that be a central thing
um instead of like people having 50 etls
that have like different
metrics that they're calculating we've
built a framework that has like
a single place for you to find a metric
you mentioned who's created this who
owns it
um how is it like how do we derive that
and people can call from that
to kind of use that themselves so we try
to look for a lot of opportunities to
centralize things
um which has been a pretty um
exciting opportunity and is that like a
data catalog
is that do you use that term or um is
that the general concept of what you're
describing
yeah um we call it the metrics in
dimension foundry
so it's like a python yaml-based system
that builds spark sql for you
and so a little bit more than a catalog
i would say
yeah i can take that jeff do you mind
going back to the mixer slide
i'll just help give it a little little
visual um
yeah there we go um so
for coordinating model versions in
production uh
currently uh where we're at with our
infrastructure is that all models kind
of get packaged up and get deployed in a
docker container and our surface through
a
kind of a json
api rest style api and
as we mentioned earlier we have mixer
which is kind of our routing layer
so in our deployment tool it's highly
optimized to like
be able to create a new application
um very quickly because as we said we're
developing new models
uh the only last three months we're
going to be spinning up a lot of
services a lot of distinct kind of model
services so
you know you can really think that kind
of on every deploy we're kind of
creating a new application
um unless we're doing like hot fixes and
bugs and so
as a result you'll see many services
you'll have kind of a
a different service deployed with a
different url
for um uh each kind of model version
number so you'll have like match scores
v12
match scores v12.2 and whatever um
each of those is deployed as kind of
like the the
implementations of interfaces so we have
a few interfaces and then we have tons
of services which are
mismatched implementations for these
these interfaces
and what mixer does is when a request
comes in it comes in for
a request will come in for the logical
like hey i want match scores
i don't really care what version as the
engineering application they don't they
don't really need to know they just want
to show
the recommendation um
in in an app what mixer does then there
it says okay it has a registry of
all the different versions so model v11
b12 you know v13
i'll have targeting rules as well say
okay this implementation
can only service women's clients because
it's an optimized model just for this
subset of the population so
it kind of goes through kind of a
a simple kind of logic and then it will
determine which are the candidate models
that it can actually communicate with
then i will go and talk to our a b
testing service and says hey
is there an active experiment running
on the logical match scores model if so
you know tell me which specific version
to control and that's through our fab
experimentation platform fully
self-service a data scientist can just
go in there and say
you know kind of drag and drop here's my
model it's you know an implementation of
match scores i want to create a test
cell 20
whatever um and then mixer automatically
integrates with that and routes the
appropriate requests
now on the shadowing front um every
single request into mixer
you know due to derek's kind of great uh
infrastructure with with uh the data
highway
every single request for a model will
generate a log with the inputs to that
model and
what decision uh or which specific model
it got routed to
that gets logged out to kafka and we go
and we'll throw that into our data
warehouse in s3
and in the shadowing mode we provide a
couple of tools so we have this local
traffic shadow
which allows you to kind of like tail
off that
that topic and filter it down to the
specific request that you care about
and route it to something on localhost
and then those uh this is for kind of
a live development experience
but then also in production what we'll
do is you can
create those tail those kind of tail
requests
set them up in production it has um it
will route
you know every request to v11 will also
get duplicated through the messaging
pipeline
and hit v12 and then what happens is
we'll automatically create um
so we use light step as our render for
for distributed trace and we'll create
light step streams so you can
go and analyze performance and error
rate for those kind of
you know core operational metrics but
those applica those uh models can also
log out the results and once again go
through the messaging infrastructure
into the data warehouse
for you to do kind of deeper analysis to
say like hey
match score v12 you know has a different
distribution
of responses than v11 and and that's
something that you can do and it's
completely safe because it's just
those uh those requests are um captured
and replayed it doesn't affect
production performance at all it's off
the log stream um and it goes all into
the data warehouse for for analysis so
we can do some
some pretty advanced stuff of deploying
new models make it very easy to deploy
new models have them shadow
any existing model um and and
capture the results and throw them in
the data warehouse for kind of deeper
analysis to figure out like
hey if i rolled this out like what would
the effect had you know try to do those
counter factuals like what would the
effect
on the business uh what it would have
been had i actually rolled out v12
it's a little kind of complicated in the
analysis we don't actually provide the
tool to
to actually do the analysis for you we
leave that to the data scientists
it's specific to that to the model in
the use case but um
yeah hope that answers the question
i'll take a stab first and i think uh i
think we all have like
what i'll say is we all have different
challenges and problems i think that's
what makes
uh part of this fun is that there's
there's no shortage of challenges and
problems
um but one of the one of the big areas
of focus for us
in the in the near-term future um
is we're really looking at how do we
think about
um i'll call it interactive uh like
inter interactive personalization or
interactive recommendations
and and what i mean by that is you know
what is the
the client experience that we can build
as you
like walk through or shop through shop
with us as you
as you navigate and experience an
interactive experience
um how do we how do we utilize
our our recommendations there in a more
real-time fashion
and so you know i'm glad that um you
know we had a question about latency
because i think that's very top of mind
for us
because i think about the what's the you
know what's the 200 millisecond
recommendation that we can make what's
the two-second
recommendation we can make and then what
is the 30-second recommendation that we
can make
um and i i think we're in an exploratory
phase that we're getting into of like
how do we balance and scale that latency
uh and scale uh you know the exploration
of like
that tension between latency and
accuracy
um and then how do we how do we provide
that in a
in an interactive way with our end
clients
and so as they navigate through our our
recommendations
uh we're getting more data as they're
they're they're interacting with it
and so then how do we use that and
update in real time
uh because every time that every time i
look at a shirt
every time i zoom in every time that i'm
like oh like this
this seems interesting right i save it
off to uh an outfit that i would
might want like all of those uh all of
those interactions
are an opportunity for us to
to to work with now i think in a
traditional
uh like e-commerce world um there's a
notion that we'll save those off
and it will update recommendations next
tomorrow
um but we're really looking and
branching into like well
why should we wait till tomorrow you're
at the site right now
so can we process something and return
back to the experience
uh within milliseconds and to evolve
that that experience in a way that your
gives you more and more to interact with
and that gives you more like the the
experience of stitchfix should become
more and more personalized uh as you you
interact with us
and so we're really moving that that
we're removing that time
horizon from like days and weeks of
calculation down to millisec seconds and
milliseconds
and and finding that feedback loop as
fast as we possibly can
and i think that's a new horizon and a
new like domain that we don't know how
that's going to look today
but we know that we know that there's a
pretty huge opportunity for us to like
build
infrastructure build interfaces and
build experiences
now that that's the high level and
i think there's a whole bunch of
challenges for each of our respective
teams
on how we have to think about the work
of the data science
scientists and how how it fits into that
world
and how the infrastructure needs to do
more uh to enable that future
so that's a high level i think uh you
know dare like we haven't heard from
derek yet so
maybe derek can give some of his
insights onto some of the
challenges that uh he's facing in the
future
yeah there were a couple things i did
want to add to that
um you know so one of the things that
we're working on and of course this this
involves my team but involves some other
teams also is we're trying to get to the
um
we're trying to make model training
easier and kind of like make that
process faster you know and so
one of the things that's involved in
that for example is you know being able
like
having a data scientist being able to
prototype a model
and the training of that model with a
smaller data set on their laptop
and then once they're happy with that
and they've done some detailed
validation of that
then turn around and run that like in a
cluster somewhere which
depending on what they're doing that
could be within spark um
or it could be something else um you
know pulling data out of magic carpet
and feeding a tensorflow model or
something like that
um so i think being able to sort of
track those
and being able to sort of run them in
different ways with data coming from
different parts of the infrastructure is
is you know definitely something we need
to um expand on and make easier
for data scientists and it's not that so
much that people can't
do this today it's just that we need to
make the process
faster more traceable and make it easy
for data scientists to go back and sort
of look at
versions and do comparisons and things
like that um so there's a lot of things
that are involved there
um you know going along with that um
we're seeing a lot of cases too where um
we've gotten like tons of mileage out of
spark for um etls
and analytics and things like that and
that's gone um really well
um but you know for machine learning
models like like
um you know there's kind of like mixed
feelings and mixed results about doing
all that in spark and so
um we use a lot of different tools that
sort of
don't play with well with spark for one
reason or another and
um but they we still need to get data
for those and
um you know we're looking at some other
ideas on how to do that where you know
for example they could
run a giant etl in spark and then move
the data to a cache somewhere that they
could
they could run through iteratively like
as they're doing iterations and
uh doing hyper parameter tuning and
reading the same data again and again
um yeah so just to give you an example
of that i mean i was just looking at um
our magic carpet uh query logs just to
see how many jobs we were running
um you know for a given day and there
are a couple days like the average
is kind of in like the 30 or 50 000 you
know individual queries you could say
every day
there was one day where it spiked over
300 000 and i'm pretty sure that was
like an iterative model run that was
like reading the same data multiple
times and
you know the good news is we have a cash
which makes that possible
um but you know there may be some other
options there
so i think like for at least in my area
and again it spans other teams as well
i think that's like a big thing that we
have to look at um and you know to make
data scientists like uh be able to
iterate through models quicker and sort
of get um
you know good results quicker because uh
that's that's just becoming
more and more important and we're seeing
examples of this um happening already
today
looking out a bit on some of the
challenges problems on the data edge
side
um yeah as jeff mentioned like a
petabyte we don't have
big data but it's definitely growing and
especially as we move more towards
capturing
what clients are doing on the website
and offering more things on our website
for clients to purchase um we have
bigger data
i think than we've had uh before and so
that growing quickly
um and that data being something that
you it's not like a
current state it's more transactional
like you know um
events that are that are constantly
happening so it's changing a bit the way
that we
process some of our data um i think
we're moving more towards doing
incremental more often historically we
didn't really
need to all the time our data wasn't so
big that we couldn't just
process everything forever and and save
it
and so along with that is just making
sure that we're thinking about
how we store our data so we've moved a
lot more towards parquet
and uh thinking about how we partition
and
file sizes as well that's something we
have to care about a lot more as we move
towards
bigger data people start to notice when
things are slower
and on the data inside we build a lot of
these core and central things that um
uh work for the data scientists but they
also feed into looker which is like
people coming in and getting kind of
metrics and they're expecting to get
those in
you know five to ten seconds and so um
when we introduce some new source that
takes
you know two to three minutes to query
that takes everybody else down with it
um so we're starting to think more about
kind of like how we serve that data
and just making sure the whole team is
really thinking about that
but also still kind of enabling the
autonomy that we have today
um so it's a thing we're thinking about
like how to address it for the next year
and make sure that
um everyone knows the implications that
it has you're going back to the data
highway for for a minute too um
i just thought of another thing that
kind of fits into this um
you know so uh lots of work going on in
that area as well i mean so we've just
expanded the size of our kafka cluster
for example
um because we're seeing you know we've
definitely seen a growth in data i mean
since we've wrote that out and
the good news another thing i'm excited
about is that our engineering team is
also going to be moving towards kafka as
well
um so we'll be um essentially sharing
data between our kafka clusters and
we'll have multiple kafka clusters
across
stitch fix instead of just one i think
that's going to open the door for a lot
more things and make us easy
make the integration between us and the
engineering teams a lot easier and
open up the door for a lot more
real-time data
as well and um
we're also seeing like some payoff from
using you know kind of frameworks around
that such as
kafka connect um you know so an example
of where that's paying off is like we
um the security team wants to get some
of our logs
and kind of capture those like to you
know have something to fall back on in
case there's
um they need to trace back through uh
api calls that have been made like
across different systems and so
uh we're writing kind of our own
connector to pull the data out of
one of our kafka topics and send it over
to um security well
they'll um warehouse that and kind of
query that um
when they want to and they're also
pulling in data from other data sources
so they can correlate these different
events
so i think um i expect more of that that
will probably be connecting more data
sources in a different variety of data
sources like uh
so so again it's kind of going along
with some of the other themes of you
know there's breadth as well as volume
that we have to
to think about so the the team has
talked a bunch about real-time data
um both in serving predictions
in dashboards and reports i'm curious
um do you folks have a notion or a
belief around
uh so-called streaming data oh yeah
the streaming is kind of related to uh
like the the data highway um kind of
enables like
streaming for for us and we have like a
couple things going on there um
you know so one we have um the system
that um
thomas's this team has built on top of
the data highway that it kind of
involves a lot of streaming um
client features um and uh
that's kind of interesting because it
allows us to
what they've done is they've allowed us
to pull additional data from
engineering databases and augment like
what's in the messages and make
make those data sets a lot richer so
that's kind of the nice thing about that
we've also got a kind of more general um
spark streaming setup that's starting to
get more
usage and we're seeing more use cases
for that pop you know pop
up um you know so we're doing things
like running some
uh you know uh constantly updating
aggregations on experiment data
uh we're looking at um a new project now
where we're going to be analyzing some
click stream data and kind of using that
to power some more uh real-time
recommendations so
we're definitely seeing a lot more of
that um over over
time and you know again moving from um
you know just doing fixes to doing fixes
plus you know a lot of interactivity
with the customers and shop is is
is definitely um going to lead to a lot
more of those over time
one uh one way that i kind of think
about
streaming data and derek kind of
mentioned this is that there's
there's like two kind of use cases so
the the
system that derek reference you know the
team built was uh
i really frame it more as like an
elaborate like
pre-caching scheme for what we do in the
data warehouse
where we have okay we have something
that computes off the snapshots that
runs every night
and then this messaging infrastructure
allows us to
update those values and i really think
about them as like you know
scalar values on on a table so there's
no kind of aggregation
to them and we kind of really leverage
that uh
it limits its use case the use cases
that it can serve but
um you know we we have kind of a need
and
a solution for that and then there's the
other dimension which uh
is really about those aggregations which
like historically we haven't
when the thing that i think
why we steered away from it historically
is
because they're they're much harder to
maintain
and because we're looking for like data
science autonomy you start to get into
these like
these uh lambda architecture style
things where you need to you know write
your logic in the streaming application
and write it in the
data warehouse for kind of batch
analysis and and
there's just kind of a higher higher
burden of
operation and so when we're focused on
kind of hey what's the roi of these kind
of investments it's just
for a long time just didn't didn't seem
to pay off um
i think now we're as dare mentioned
we're revisiting a lot of these things
around
like streaming aggregations um
because we're starting to see more use
cases for where it can pay off
but it's something that we've been
reluctant to do in the past just because
the operational burden
of these kind of lambda architectures is
is quite high
um and and not very amenable to like
individual data science autonomy
i'll say a quick tidbit before i pass
off to jeff to close this on this one
i'd say your your team structure is
going to evolve
similar to how your systems evolve and
so it depends on scale
like jeff mentioned that like we now
have laura and her team and like that's
a
it's a fantastic addition to the team um
but you know when you're five to ten
like there's that that is the team
um and so i think i think a lot about
the similarities between how systems
scale and how organizations scale
and so my my short answer is that it
will evolve over time as your chain
as your domains change jeff
yeah i mean that that is a very good
answer i mean i can tell a little bit
about how we're structured um
specifically at statistics and
to bruce's point it's not um
not the right shape for for everyone and
it's not always been the right shape for
us so it's it's
what we think is the right shape for us
right now um
but uh you know something that's unique
uh to stitch hooks
is um
we have a chief algorithms officer
and so that that means that our data
science org
is sort of a top-level
org in the company which uh most
companies
you would see it under engineering or um
i don't know and in other maybe more
crazy places like i've seen it under
finance i've seen other operations
it's not its citrix and so that means we
have
an engineering team and we have an
algorithms team
and and under that algorithms team we've
put
our sort of horizontal infrastructure so
our data platform
and the folks on the call today um a lot
of companies are going to deploy that
sort of a shared
infrastructure across all of the
technology or gets to checks
um we see our data platform as kind of a
support org
um to to enable data science and that's
just
sort of a um
it's it's uh due to the fact that we see
data science as a
key differentiator um to the company and
so we want to
basically allow um maximize focus of
our infrastructure on enabling
that algo development um and so
so from an infrastructure perspective
we've got the folks on the call we see
them as
horizontal and it's roughly split
between online serving machine to
machine which is thomas
um machine to human which is um
we we had a slide on it but basically
like all of the dashboarding and um
uh interactive kind of data
visualization data product
uh stuff and then um uh our
data infrastructure teams which is uh
derrick right so like kind of that core
batch infrastructure and
um uh um etl
uh scheduling and deployment um as well
as
uh all the rnd and and streaming um
use cases um and then on the data
science side
like those are mostly um again
uh vertical teams right so like
those are full stack data scientists
that are working um
on vertical business problems so that's
typically
um functional partnerships within the
business so
like merchandising we have a
merchandising data science team
um we have a big styling operations
group and
um you know personal styling and our
stylists are a key aspect of our
business
we have a styling algorithms team at
stitchfix
um and then uh the client experience
again is
um you know some combination of
marketing marketing technology um as
well as
um uh now like the fairly rich
um uh an interactive client experience
that we're building out on the website
and so we have a client algorithms team
that focuses on
um those sort of data products um and
over time
we've seen more horizontal kind of work
evolve from that
so you know laura's team building the
core data model
um is an example of sort of like
horizontalization of um data and use and
then like horizontalization of like r d
and data products are things like um uh
a team that focuses on global
optimization of
our merchandise across channels for
example or um
thomas talked about this probability of
purchase so given an item and a client
was the probability that they're gonna
purchase that
um that has applications that are pretty
ubiquitous across
our um uh vertical stacks right and so
we see those as now horizontal
teams that are deployed in the org um
and so anyway that's kind of a snapshot
of how we're organized today and
just maybe also like an insight into the
evolution of that is as things become
more ubiquitous they become more
horizontalized
but our default is like this sort of
full stock deployment of
data scientists integrated into a
business function or sort of a
business context that they're working
through
well thank you thank you jeff and um
thank you to all of you for joining us
it was great to have you here and i
really appreciate you sharing your
insight and experience
with the community um how can folks find
you
um if they want to ask follow-up
questions i can just have them you know
email me and i can be the human the
human router or
oh here we go at stitchfix underscore
algo on twitter
yeah feel free to tweet us and then uh i
don't know if anybody wants to
screenshot
we've got all of our contact info up
here but we do actively monitor that uh
twitter account and love to engage there
as well as email or
feel free to to utilize pete's offer to
um
wrap questions to us as well great
excellent
all right well thanks again for joining
us awesome well thank you so much
you